in this modern era Tommy will not allow
the movie the original movie to stream
he doesn't want it to stream he sells
the DVDs and when you buy a DVD of the
room this is enclosed inside now it just
looks like this is a postcard of Tommy
that's Tommy right there but then you
flip it over and it's an order form for
Tommy Wiseau underwear and it's the
different kinds of underwear that I
guess he has designed is that correct I
have a pair sleeping is very comfortable
very is it they made for women no oh
okay that's strange
yeah I asked so we did a press
conference for the hf PF for the golden
globes right
they liked the movie so much they asked
actually asked for Tommy to have his own
press conference which was bizarre as
heck but he showed up and I asked him I
was like hey Tommy you uh you wearing
the underwear he goes yeah I uh I got
mighty double use the Tommy Wiseau is
the TW and then he goes wash out James
in this in this climate you don't want
to be asking about my underwear you know
maybe I'll sue you
you